negative people love to hang out with
negative people love hanging out with
each other and saying why everybody else
is [ __ ] up my mom [ __ ] up our boss
[ __ ] up the ceo [ __ ] up billionaires
[ __ ] up gen z [ __ ] up the
millennials like when did you [ __ ] up
when did you [ __ ] up how many questions
did you get i didn't count but a lot
what do you think
60. i love it i can't wait to this is
like a fun new format we're thinking
about which is like things like that
stressed me out have been stressed all
day that we weren't gonna get to
everybody and so so many people want the
question
and so now it's like even more fun right
because at my live events we'll record
them i'm going to answer them all we may
not post them all
but if you asked if they asked i'm going
to [ __ ] find a way to answer them all
you've worked to send to people 101 or
put them on the askgaryvee team gary
account or whatever we figured to [ __ ]
out but um really fun new innovation on
dealing with the reality of the supply
and demand of our new realities um and
just a lot of like fun people people
flying in from romania people flying in
from [ __ ]
you know like down the street
all walks of life all different
scenarios all different challenges all
different opportunities all different
levels of happiness
and hope optimism and delusion and
that's just like the world right the
world is just filled with so many
different truths and people's truths
change hour by hour day by day people's
truths have changed in line today since
v con
right there many people i saw in
minnesota in may that have a different
reality right now in late july
in seven weeks somebody got sick
something popped off in a good way and
so you know everyone's always looking
for answers
when
answers are always changing and evolving
based on the questions and questions are
coming up on a daily basis
so this is not about a tactical like
here's the blueprint go do this this is
about a perspective
and a sustainable mental framework that
allows you to
deal with anything and everything and
that is grounded in
gratitude and that is grounded in
practical optimism that is grounded
tactically in underpriced attention and
opportunities that's why you're going to
hear from me so much about facebook
pages and youtube shorts now because the
attention and where you need to put your
energy your output your content your
information your music your art your
ideas your business development those
will change
um but
what everyone is in search of and in
need of
is a sustainable mental framework and
and that is what i'm going to continue
to work on which is like if you're able
to see the world through the eyes of
attacking hate with love
through the eyes of
tenacity and work ethic are part of the
formula thus find something you like
otherwise you won't be able to work that
hard
you know if if you're able to figure
that out if you are stuck in a nine to
six bring even a nine to nine because
you have two jobs in your situation such
a challenge because you're feeding four
people in your home as a single parent
and you've got two jobs you're nine to
nine the question is can one of those
because one of them's just extra cash
instead of having a five to nine where
you're actively doing something can you
get a five to nine for the same fifteen
dollars an hour at a store or be a
receptionist or a night guard where you
can work on your phone while you
actually do your job right it's like
you know to me the ques you know this
concept
of people saying well i'm stuck
is just actually not true it's true
because you think you're stuck
the actual
world god the world doesn't think you're
stuck you just haven't figured out the
move you have to make to unstuck you
and unstick you and that's exactly what
i just said in that little scenario
right now which is like you're working
five to nine
but like you're doing something that
doesn't let you be on your phone but you
switch it and get paid the same amount
and sit at a chair
that's not bothered often security guard
retail cash register where that's not a
busy store uh front uh secretary uh you
know um
driving movers around and every time
you're not driving like maybe that's
half and half there
i'm just spinning here free flow about
you're not stuck you might have it much
more challenging than others that's why
i go so crazy about 20 year olds
20 year olds
so many of them don't have the handcuffs
that's why i'm so passionate about 20 to
30. i'm not less passionate about 50 to
90.
it's just that 50 to 90 comes with
baggage comes with being a little stuck
children mortgages
debt
20 to 30 comes with just opportunity and
just got to get the [ __ ] out of the
school system and parents traditional
[ __ ] points of view they have plenty
of good points of view this is not
binary parents are the best parents are
the worst school's the best school's
worst i'm the best i'm the worst
everything is both
everybody just wants to be one thing
it's got to be all blue it's got to be
all red it's [ __ ] purple
[ __ ]
it's always purple
nothing's binary but what is binary is
if you are pessimistic and you say
you're stuck then it's over
if you've decided it's over there ain't
no [ __ ] video i can make to make you
on over
or there is which is why i'm motivated
to do it the fact that one human being
can say one thing at the right second to
another human being that can
fundamentally change the process of
their life because they have now decided
to open up a different perspective and
see the world differently is the most
intoxicating most powerful reason that
human beings are the best in the world
and i will continue to be one small
version of a human being one of many
millions of people that are out there
and i don't i don't know if i think it's
billions but i definitely think it's
tens of millions and i do believe it's
hundreds of millions
do i think it's 12 percent of people
maybe not but but i definitely think
there are tens to hundreds of millions
of people who get deep happiness for
themselves out of trying to be a
communicator to help others some do it
at the highest level of distribution
like me others do it for their just
their child thus making me change my
mind it is billions of people it is
billions of people there's absolutely
over a billion people on earth that are
passionate to use their words to make
somebody's life better it's called
parented and so [ __ ]
what are we doing here like
enough
enough let this be the rant in the back
of a car this time what was supposed to
be a two second recap
of this
[ __ ] fox signing
in la let this little rant be the one
that says he's [ __ ] right
because if you say i'm wrong
nobody's going to be able to help you
you're going to be the only person
that's able to help yourself
and if you think
the people that are using
fear and negativity
to get your attention and you're saying
they're right they're just selling you
darkness and you're buying it
and for some reason you think that if
you take that darkness and then you
deploy hating somebody else a system a
government a president
hating
a gender a race
a person that looks different than you
that you're going to take your
unhappiness you're going to repackage it
because somebody got into your head and
you're going to use that as hate to tear
down somebody else because you think
that's going to be good for you you
think that's going to be good for you
you're [ __ ] losing out here
partner you're [ __ ] losing out here
my friend
if you're [ __ ] spending your time
hating on others
canceling people on the left hating on
people on the right
country to country religion to religion
if you're watching this in the middle
east in eastern europe in america trying
to divide people
even within your own family you're mad
at your brother because he's happy and
successful
that's on you
he's not trying to make you feel bad
he's just happy he can't help but
protect it he's happy and so what you're
mad at him you want to tear him down you
want to talk [ __ ] to your other siblings
or your parents about him because he's
happy
this is an inside game it's you versus
you
it's you with you it's only you and you
and too many of you right now
are succumbing to consuming darkness
and that's your [ __ ] [ __ ] up
so take on the accountability
take on the accountability
and say it's my job to start being more
optimistic and happier and i'm going to
seek out humans and content that does
that this is the first day that i'm
going to go on the mental scale just
like when you have to lose 30 pounds you
go into scale and be like okay i'm a
buck 90 i got to get to 160. let this be
the video let this be the second in your
life that you get on the mental scale
and say i'm too cynical i'm too scared
i'm frightened i'm insecure which is why
all this other bad shit's happening
and i'm ready to do something about it
and that first thing to do is to cut out
the negativity in your life cut the news
the [ __ ] out cut all the people on your
[ __ ] social that are [ __ ] negative
cut the people in your real life cut
them down you don't have to cancel and
completely cut out your mom you just
might be able to talk to her once a
month for five minutes instead of three
times a day for 15 and just have her
talk negative nonsense to you
you know that's the biggest issue that
people people hear me they're like i
can't cut my brother out i don't want
you to
i want you to
cut down your brother
limit your brother
if your brother is [ __ ] bringing
negativity to you an hour at a time
every single day that is seeping into
your
soul look around your homies
negative people love to hang out with
negative people
negative people love to hang out with
negative people you just sit in a
[ __ ] circle on your text thread or in
your [ __ ]
at your [ __ ] coffee shop in the
morning or after work at the bar or on
the softball team or in the office
you just love hanging out with each
other and saying why everybody else is
[ __ ] up
joe biden [ __ ] up donald trump [ __ ]
up my mom [ __ ] up
our boss [ __ ] up the co [ __ ] up
billionaires [ __ ] up
gen z [ __ ] up the millennials like
when did you [ __ ] up
wouldn't you [ __ ] up you know what keeps
me happy as [ __ ] i talk to myself more
about what i [ __ ] up about than what
i've accomplished and let me make it
very clear to you i'm incredibly proud
of how big one list is versus the other
and yet all my focus goes on to the
accountability of what i suck at and
that doesn't bring me down that makes me
happy
because i take on the accountability i'm
like what can i do about it how do i
make it better what can i do about it
can that be apologizing to somebody
or can that be about changing my
behavior
often both
negative people think they're tricking
somebody with their negative words
i come across negative people every day
of my life
and i listen to all of their nonsense
and they really think they're tricking
me
into thinking it was someone else it's
[ __ ] you
if you can afford it therapy if you
can't afford it use the free therapy
that's on youtube and podcast every
[ __ ] day
[ __ ] do something about it
because one day you're gonna wake up and
it's gonna all be over and you're gonna
be dead forever
and you're going to regret it
it's time change your life because
nobody else is going to change it for
you there'll be people that come along
that want to be the assist i'd love to
be the assist
i'd love to [ __ ] be the assist
boy would i love to be the assist
i'd love to bounce it right down the
lane and have you dunk it
but i can't be the one that scores the
points that needs to be you
[Music]
you